boris johnson leaving
a new york shopping center fighting
constitutional political
and now legal roadblocks as well as
being accused of the gravest of
political crimes
misleading the monarch jeremy corbyn
trying his best to distract from the
biggest political fight between
government and politicians
since the founding of the supreme court
a decade ago
he tried to look like he was taking the
tumult in his stride
and refusing to alter his new york
schedule but his message was clear
one of defiance and a determination to
keep going
for the avoidance of doubt i have the
highest
uh respect of course for our judiciary
and for the independence
of our courts but i must say i strongly
disagree
uh with this judgment boris johnson
trying
as far as is humanly possible to
continue with business as normal in new
york today
meeting president trump and a speech at
the un
aides say he is enormously frustrated
with the decision
of the supreme court he is now facing a
political
constitutional and legal crisis that
leaves him
like the building that he stood in front
of today on a road to nowhere
but the bad news didn't stop coming this
document was released by the high court
earlier this month
revealing the minutes of a cabinet
conference call but with some of the
most sensitive bits blocked out in black
but sky news has obtained these
contentious sections proving yet
more embarrassment for the government
the minutes of the legal opinion given
by the attorney general jeffrey cox say
that
his advice on the question of the law is
that this was lawful
and within the constitution any
accusations of
unlawfulness or constitutional outrage
were motivated by political
considerations
i think the attorney is going to have to
consider his position
because he's now had a unanimous
decision of the supreme court completely
the other way indicating the prime
minister's acted
unlawfully it wasn't the only
resignation demand of the day
cross-party support for the prime
minister to stand down
now building he does not want to have to
answer questions about his disastrous
brexit policy and in doing so he was
prepared to mislead
the queen and indeed to mislead the
whole country
he is not fit for office he should
resign
in new york the prime minister was
always going to find a friendly face in
donald trump
it's great to be with my friend boris
johnson and just
got a position that he's having a very
easy time with it's much easier than you
thought
i just said is it tougher or easier he
said well it's i guess what he expected
i think it's pretty much what you
expected
in new york the prime minister was
always going to find one ally
in donald trump but the situation he now
faces
is far from an easy time it's
unprecedented and completely unknown
sam coates sky news new york